[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv and
recorded
on thursday january the 28th this week's
cover story
the vaccine wars turn nasty in europe
we'll take a look at the eu's temper
tantrum over its sluggish supply
and ask if this is a sign of things to
come
schools and border controls have
dominated domestic news this week the
spectators
political team will report on the latest
developments
we'll head down under to discover how
australia's travel quarantine
system has worked and on the 300th
anniversary of the creation of the
office
of prime minister we'll speak to
historian and biographer anthony selden
on who's been the best and the worst
plus why is there no
museum of prime ministers all that to
come
in the next hour if you subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel
why wouldn't you it's free you'll never
miss a program just click the subscribe
button at the bottom right
of the screen now and as always a very
special thanks to
charles stanley for their continued
support
of the week in 60 minutes this year
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms one of
the oldest companies
on the london stock exchange and we are
delighted to have them
as our partners britain passed a
miserable milestone of a hundred
thousand
covert deaths this week it's a grim
statistic a
terrible toll which puts even more
pressure on the vaccine rollout
not just to lead us out of lockdown but
to slash fatalities
so far it's so good but there is some
way to go yet i'm joined by kate andrews
the editor of the spectators daily
covert 19 updale update email you should
get that is the only roundup you need
for the latest coronavirus news in
britain and abroad
kate update us and go through the latest
numbers please
as you can see here cases peaked around
the start of the year
and are now showing a clear trajectory
of decline
with cases hovering around where they
were say december
20th roughly last year when tier 4 had
been brought in for millions
of people but other areas of the uk
remain slightly more
liberalized as we know with this virus
there is a lag between infection and
hospitalization and you would expect if
cases were dropping at the start of the
month
that we would now start to see a decline
in hospitalization
this is by no means reflecting the
decline that you saw in cases in that
previous slide
but we have had some positive news from
the health service journal this morning
uh showing that case uh that covered
positive patients in english hospitals
fell by nearly 1 500 yesterday
and they're describing that as the
biggest daily decline
recorded since the start of the pandemic
it reflects another big decline just
over a thousand
on the 17th of april which was the start
of a very
steep descent and but the fact
is andrew as you say we've hopefully
turned the tide on this wave of the
virus
but that's not what's in the main news
this week
the stark number of the week is a
hundred thousand and that represents the
uk's accumulative
death toll coveted death toll since last
spring
the prime minister addressed the nation
this week saying he was deeply sorry
that he accepts responsibility
in his handling of this crisis something
that will no doubt be looked at in an
inquiry
down the line but i think there's little
doubt that the government wants
certain parts of the crisis focused on
more
than others and that is what is embodied
in the vaccine race and i can give you
an update on that
um now i don't want to get too
optimistic uh because we are a year into
this crisis the uk is in its third
lockdown so
let's not pretend things can't go wrong
but so far it is looking like quite a
remarkable success story
the uk's decision last year not to join
the european union and procuring
vaccines and going in alone instead
looks to be one of the best decisions
it's made during the crisis as well as
the idea to invest
across the board in multiple vaccines
despite at the time people thinking
there was a relatively low probability
that any of them would work and they
secured
over 350 million doses and that's
more than four jabs per adult
so that has been a a remarkable success
for the uk
and what you're looking at here in this
graph has prompted some pretty
wild behavior from the european union
this week which understandably is
growing increasingly
desperate to get their hands on the
vaccine and but
less understandably has started to
undermine diplomacy
and order this includes warning that it
might restrict exports of vaccines made
in the block a suggestion of the erosion
of contract law
rejecting the notion of first come first
served now the uk is trying to stay out
of it
uh they're saying that this is this is a
dispute between the eu
and big pharma and the providers but it
is likely to be drawn in further
especially if pressure starts to mount
for the uk once it's most vulnerable
members of the population are vaccinated
to donate these vaccines um to the rest
of europe
um but there are other political
problems for the uk other fights to be
had um and this is a a graph showing
uh the the rate of vaccinations within
the four nations
and highlights a problem that boris
johnson has
not that england isn't doing well um but
he's up in scotland today
making the case for the union um an
issue that is becoming um
an increasing pressure point for the
prime minister and it's charts like this
that the prime minister will use to make
his case
that the union is stronger together that
westminster really had a handle not just
on procuring these vaccines
but also knowing how to administer them
and but these are crucial weeks for the
prime minister he needs to meet his
target of mid-february by having the
most for
vulnerable groups inoculated um again
reasons to be hopeful the current
projections and forecasts would suggest
that the uk might hit this target a day
or two
early which you can see in this graph
which you can see in this graph but
this is this is not just about turning
the tide on the virus it's very much
from a political perspective
perspective about turning the tide on
how we view this government it's
handling of coven 19 and how efficient
it really is
um on that note i'll throw back over to
you andrew thank you for that let me
bring in
uh james forsyth our political editor
and katie bowens our deputy
political editor to reflect on this
week's uh politics james the
the this milestone of a hundred thousand
deaths from covert which places amongst
per capita amongst the worst terms of
performance the the human toll
is obvious and huge is the prime
minister
paying a political toll for it as well
not in the way i think that many people
in westminster had expected i still
think the public
don't view the virus they view the virus
as a kind of natural disaster in the way
that they would view
flooding or a hurricane rather than as a
kind of straightforward political issue
and so while i think the government does
obviously you know you look at how big
the government's leads were early in
this crisis when the rally round the
flag effect was in
was in full force and where they are now
you obviously
the mistakes may have taken a toll on
the government's poll ratings
but we're still in a situation where
labour are marginally ahead
uh you go up today getting a slightly
bigger lead than usual four points
but yeah we're still kind of we're still
in a world where the two parties are
are if you can average out the poles
neck and neck and i think you
i mean the big question as as k andrew
said in terms of the public's view on
this is
what happens with the vaccine roll out
because i think that if at the end of
this crisis the uk is
coming out of it before other countries
then i think the public will
take a more benign view of the
government's handling of the whole
crisis
is that the politics of it that the the
mistakes of the government made in 2020
uh were many some of them very big and
they're pretty well cataloged now we
know
what they are from test and trace to
protective equipment and other things
being slow
to lock down when it should have done
but is the thought in government that in
the end that won't matter so much if
if they get the vaccine roll out right
in other words
what will stay in people's memories is
is is a successful
exit from the pandemic rather than the
unsuccessful
periods of the pandemic last year
yes i i do think now the focus in
government is actually you can turn
things around by having that positive
vaccine story
you see it this week lots of coverage of
the fact we have passed a hundred
thousand deaths but also lots of
coverage of this
positive vaccine development and there's
that juxtaposition going i think there's
still difficult points for the
government
i think if you look at the figures and
how we've reached a hundred thousand
the number of deaths from november is
really startling
uh you know this wasn't all in the first
wave in fact uh i think this idea the
government had which you make mistakes
in the beginning
i think you could argue they made
mistakes up until very recently
um but but ultimately i think the sense
in number 10
is if they can keep up uh the pace
currently on vaccinations
if they can be the leading country
across europe
then that's what people are going to
remember and that is what you're going
to get to this summer and
i think it's no coincidence that there
is lots of talk about postponing the
local elections in may
all of a sudden the government are quite
keen to have them that's because they
think they're getting a vaccine boost
james when the government announced that
it was not going to be part of the eu
procurement uh
approach uh which it could have been as
i understand
even though we were no longer in the eu
uh the sort of the the london chattering
classes uh went
mad saying how disgraceful this is is
this is nationalism run riot and
brexiteer and nutters and so on
they're not saying that now aren't they
no and i think what it is
i think it showcases the the the the
advantages of being a nimble country
being able to move quickly not having to
move at the slowest
pace uh the uk basically went for
emergency authorization rather than the
full authorization that the european
medicines agency is going through with
these vaccines
and the uk is is essentially trying to
try to get the vaccine rolled out as
fast as it is produced and i think that
that is
that has given the uk an advantage i
think the other big advantage the uk has
is that it has a the population in
europe that is by far the most willing
to take the vaccine
so that means that you don't have to go
slowly to try and build public
confidence in the way that it's
happening in some other countries i
don't think it's any coincidence
but denmark is one of the eu countries
that has made the most progress
and that has the second most
pro-vaccination population in europe
after the uk i think that that public
willingness to take the vaccine
is a crucial part of the success of the
uk vaccine rollout
whereas in france which is a rather
surprisingly quite frighteningly large
anti-vaxx
movement um so far less than two percent
of the population have had
the vaccine we we've seen brussels sort
of beat the drum this week
james almost implying that they may be
looking at stopping pfizer
exports from there to the united kingdom
kind of implying that britain should be
sending over a chunk of its
astrazeneca supplies to
uh the eu the european press
very unimpressed with brussels's uh
record so far how do you think this is
going to work out
well i i i think the uk government is
very keen to stay out of this row
um because i think it i think it fears
that the uh that there are
european politicians looking for any
excuse to essentially say well we're
halting
these advisor exports to the uk so the
uk is very keen to stay out of it but
one thing i would say is
look at the amount of noise the eu is
making in this round
if you are confident that you have a
legal remedy to your problem
you tend not to make a public song and
dance about it you just instruct your
lawyers
so i think i think the fact that the the
eu is making this much
of a you know talking about the
astrazeneca societal and moral
obligations
suggest that it isn't confident of a
legal remedy i mean the uk's view is
but when they uh that oxford university
came to uk government said look we want
you to be happy
with the vaccine deal we are negotiating
considering its importance
and the uk government said look we want
a
legally watertight guarantee that the uk
will have first
access to the doses produced in this
country
that actually led to oxford not
partnering with
mark the the pharmaceutical company that
they were expected to
and instead with a bit of government
matchmaking pastor and partnering with
astrazeneca
but that is because the uk got more in
its contract than just a best effort
scores best endeavors clause
which is what the ceo of astrazeneca
says the eu has
in its contract with astrazeneca so i
think the the uk i think he's on
stronger legal ground here
uh in terms of having first refusal on
the supply coming out of the uk
i think that it would be um it would be
a massive step for all the reasons that
kate said out in our presentation
if the the eu were to go down the route
that the german government is advocating
and impose full on export controls on
vaccines from the block if you had a
situation where
pfizer were unable to fulfill a contract
that has been signed and paid for with
the uk government because of eu action
that that would be quite a massive
escalation
and casey we've seen some some strange
stories that got going
around this um not not just
the uh the health commissioner from
greece saying
you know we don't we don't believe in
first come first serve but
this story in handles blatt which uh the
german financial paper which is apparent
i know a little bit about this paper it
has a
incredible reverence for facts you know
it facts checks everything
as a kind of almost germanic
thoroughness about how it reports things
and yet it came out with a report that
said the
astrazeneca uh vaccine was only
effective
for eight percent of over 65s which
the german government and astrazeneca
both said is nonsense
and yet it doubled down on the story uh
what does the british government make of
all this i think
ministers are perplexed i think there's
also a sense of annoyance i think some
are actually seeing at what they see as
disinformation
in terms of uh what's coming out because
also i think there's a sense you touch
on the fact that publication is known
for
actually wanting to publish facts i
think there is a there is a sense that
this isn't coming from nowhere
i think they worry that someone is
actually negatively briefing uh
within government against uh the oxford
vaccine perhaps for reasons if you look
at the whole events of the week
and as you say the publication doubled
down and i think it
it adds to this thing it's there is a
huge row going on at the moment about
you know vaccine wars about the oxford
vaccine about the lack of supply
the eu haven't yet approved the oxford
vaccine they can't actually use it yet
i think they're you know several million
doses ready to go when when they do
approve it
but i think we're looking ahead now to
friday
when we're expecting it could be
approved and while
uh i think the eight percent efficacy uh
line has been
widely rebuffed you've had you know the
german government come out against it
i think that where these publications
are still saying
there could be something is is it going
to be approved for the elderly is there
going to be an age limit in the eu
approval and i think
the only way we're going to find out the
truth in terms of the smoke and mirrors
at the moment
is a jail that's having an incredibly
bad week or is there something more to
it is when they
announce their decision on approval well
uh vaccine wars is the cover story of
the spectator
this week it's got a great cover and
it's a two-page spread
on what's going on by matthew lynn it's
well worth a read
james and katie stay with us there's
more politics to talk about but
let me for the moment welcome professor
david salisbury he's an immunization
expert
he's held roles at the who and the
department of health among other places
professor welcome
to spectator tv can i just come right in
on one factual question that
it is right in your view that
astrazeneca's vaccine
is only works
for eight percent that's not right is it
professor i can't find that figure
anywhere i just don't know where they
got that
from what it relates to let me stand
back a little bit professor
because not not much
less than a year ago the view from
experts seemed to be that it
could take 10 years to get a vaccine
it could be done less than that but it
was going to be a long while
and i suppose sometimes in the
day-to-day news that we get we
we don't quite realize the amazing thing
that's happened because here we are
less than a year into this pandemic and
i think we've
we've now got um well three vaccines are
operating and china and russia have
theirs too
it is a remarkable scientific
achievement is it not
no it's fantastic and nobody should ever
take that away from what has been
achieved to
got from nothing to vaccines
already being implemented in this period
of time is an extraordinary achievement
and it's not just an extraordinary
achievement for now
for coronavirus i think that the whole
future of
the way in which we make vaccines is
going to change
and the rna vaccines that are synthetic
you basically take the gene and you make
the
the vaccine based on the gene and away
you go
transformative and we we've become
familiar with the fisa vaccine because
it was the the first on the block and
then of course
the oxford astrazeneca won and there's a
third one that was approved i think
first in america
we now hear that this johnson and
johnson vaccine
coming along which apparently please
correct me if i'm wrong here
you only need one jab you don't need a
follow-up jab
that that could be a huge game-changer
professor what's your view on that
i think we need to wait and see quite
what comes out from the
data for jnj and what it gets licensed
for
and there have been studies on two doses
on that vaccine as well
i think we need to just be a bit
cautious about thinking that we will
have
one dose and if we do have one dose
vaccines and they are effective
and the immunity lasts again great
advance
really welcome but let's just hold back
on that because
so far many of the other vaccines are
clearly two dose
right yeah it's interesting why that one
is different
on we in the united kingdom we
vaccinated as of this morning about 7.5
million
uh but only under half a million have
had their second
dose are you comfortable with
the emphasis on getting the first jab
done
even at the expense of a second job
being delayed
medically is that something that you're
comfortable with yeah i've been a strong
proponent of this
from even before it was ever announced
that it seemed to me that it's a sort of
no-brainer
um and the numbers are so obvious if you
have
a million people and you give them two
doses
at 95 percent efficacy you protect
950 000 of them now take 2 million
people
give them one dose even if the efficacy
was as low as 60 percent
and you know it's not but even if it
were that's 1.2 million protected
it's it's just so straightforward if we
want to save lives
give first doses to as many people as we
can
then you catch up with the second doses
and is there a time limit for the second
dose to be effective
well we don't know that what we do know
is from
general principles about vaccines
actually the longer interval you have
between the doses
the better the immune response the
shorter the
interval the more you push getting a
good immune response
so there's a lot in favor of these
delayed
second doses fascinating now how
comfortable are you
or how worried are you i should say with
this fear i've seen expressed that will
the vaccines that we have will it handle
these
variants these mutations we see the kent
ovarian south african variant and so on
is that a cause for concern i think it
is and i think we have to be very
careful about
the assumptions for the long term
because we know that the vaccine is
effective
so far against the uk
variant we've we've got enough people
saying we've tested this
we've got concerns about south africa
and brazil
one of the other things that i think
we've learned is that you can change
these vaccines
quickly because of the way in which
they're made
and i think that we have to look at the
model that we've long been comfortable
with
which is flu vaccination where pretty
much
every year we have a new flu vaccine
and we've learned how to do that and
we've learned how to anticipate that
so i can see the future being
a coronavirus vaccine just like our flu
vaccine every autumn
the problem i see in the short term
about this
is if we got variants that the vaccine
didn't work against what do we do with
all the people that we've just
vaccinated and i think we've got to just
plan ahead for something like that
but maybe that's me being very worried
no
it's always clearly it's a it's
something that we can't forget
that uh it's not a straight line to uh
getting out of this pandemic that there
are potholes and
rocks uh in in the road and we need to
be uh aware of
of that and i thank you for making that
uh point professor how
how do you assess the robustness of our
supply chains as we
we ramp up uh the vaccines um
are we going to get to the government's
targets do you think
well if you look if you extrapolate from
where we
are to where they want to be in
mid-february i think it it's looking
good
vaccine campaigns are about three things
and they all have to come together
in the same place at the same time
supply
people to do the vaccinating people to
be vaccinated
the second and third i think are looking
really good
and the first depends entirely on what
the manufacturers can give us
and whether perhaps we may be uh
restrained
on what it is that we're going to get
although
i think there's a bit of a bit of a hot
air
currently being blown in our direction
what do you mean by that well you know
if you have a contract in place
for a certain amount of vaccine
if somebody says well by the way you
can't have that because we're gonna have
it
actually the supplier is then in breach
of contract
so you know whilst the eu is
talking about az for instance being in
breach of contract with them
if they were to find a way of of
having our contracted vaccine
diverted then azad would be in breach of
contract with the uk
so they are stuck in the middle and
there are other issues that they just
aren't
the eu that is aren't talking about
and one of them firstly if the vaccine
that they want is being produced in the
uk
has that production been licensed for
europe
and that's a really big question have
they looked at all of the manufacturing
and even silly things like the
packages and the leaflets that go in the
packages
for uk production are in english
yes you know just to say we want some of
your vaccine
is an awfully long way from getting it
legally
because i saw somewhere that one of the
things that's holding things up in
europe was the need
or the demand to have uh the
instructions in
24 or 25 different languages which has
uh held things
up how much uh professor
of the population has to be vaccinated
uh for the pandemic
really to recede as a threat
oh that's tough the there are two
sections to this
firstly how many people you've got to
protect to protect them
in other words the high risk group and
the answer is as many of you as you
possibly can if not all
how many of those people who are not in
the high risk group do you have to
vaccinate
to stop transmission so that they don't
spread it
and if you took an estimate of roughly
65 percent of the population
immune well you've got to vaccinate more
than 65 percent of them to get there
so we've got a quite a way to go we're
doing fantastically well
protecting the vulnerable i think it's
going to be a much harder call
when we try to vaccinate the younger
people
for whom the benefit is much less and so
they don't necessarily see themselves
at the same risk and they may not come
forward in the same numbers
and if we don't get them we don't stop
transmission
and we will still be living with this
virus for a while
and from being vaccinated to being
more immune to the vaccine how long is
the period because it's not right away
is it
no i mean if you again look at the sort
of the data from the trials
and the it's between two and three weeks
after your first dose
and you know for safety's sake people
are talking about
wait you know three weeks you will have
lots of antibodies and you should
be well protected and we then need to
make sure that later on we get our
second doses to fulfill that protection
professor just a final question that in
these dark times with the lockdown
still pretty severe in the uk and
elsewhere we passed that
terrible milestone of a hundred thousand
deaths from
covid uh is it possible to
to raise our spirits and look to a time
perhaps before this year is out when
there will be a surplus of vaccines
and we can actually start sending
vaccines to places
that at the moment don't have them or
can't afford them
i think that's absolutely right and i
hope that's the way of the future
if you look at the uk you look at the us
you look at
canada we've all got on contract
far more vaccine than we could ever need
and i think that what people
should do is as we get to
a degree of comfort about our own
programs
offer vaccine out of our contracts so
that we don't
draw them down recycling vaccines is
much more difficult if you've already
got them in stock
it's much harder to send them on to
someone else
but if you've got contracts that you
have not
drawn down for goodness sake offer those
vaccines to other people that want to
take them
indeed uh professor that's a good point
for us to end on professor salisbury
thank you for joining us on spectator
tv today let me go back to james forsyth
and katie balls and
go to you uh katie because you in in the
magazine this week you've published your
interview
with the children's commissioner and
longfield she's just stepping down after
a number of years in the job and in a
way
it's quite a depressing interview
because of
the emphasis that she puts on this huge
mental health issues that have developed
from
among children during lockdown and many
more suffering from it and it's
not a problem that can be overcome very
quickly to tell us more about what she
told you
yes you're right it makes for
uncomfortable reading because while as
children's commissioner she's keen to
get children back in the classroom as
soon as possible
which could be early march now we know
it's not after the february half term
immediately
and her point is even if you do that
there's this huge
overhang there are so many problems
created from the past
year of children being out of the
classroom
of the pandemic that's going to take a
real uh you know concentrated effort
from the government a catch-up program
which
isn't just about education which is
clearly an issue in terms of the
inequality
between the advantage and the
disadvantage exacerbated by the pandemic
but also just the effect on children's
mental health we've seen
a rise in the number of children
identifying with a
mental health disorder also a rise in
eating disorders specifically
and i think we're just entering
uncharted territory in the sense that no
one is quite sure
how long how hard this is going to be to
reverse and
she said to me that she thinks for all
this talk of a you know a two-year
program
that might be needed she thinks this
could actually be up to you know three
to five years
of efforts going to be needed to try and
remedy some of the harms
she uh thought there was a need for a
nationwide mobilization
to repair the damage she told you in the
interview
that has been done to our children
she called it a nightingale moment that
we needed to
as what we had done with building the
nightingale hospitals
we needed that kind of concentrated
effort to deal with the mental health
issues that are developing among
children as you say
had to go on for a long time i can see
the sense of all that
i also just wonder whether the the
demands on government
as we come out of the pandemic as we
hope we will the demands of government
are going to be huge i just
wonder how we could ever cope with all
this that it has to do
exactly i mean there's a bandwidth issue
as it is and i think
the frustration that she has is that
when she points to the nightingale
furlough
she believes when there is political
will things do happen
and i think that it's essentially also
here i think from the
chair of the education select committee
rob hartford in parliament
which is there is just this concern that
education is not seen as one of the
absolute top priorities yes everyone's
keen to say it's really important
but if you look at actions they think
it's become a second-tier issue
i think in terms of mental health and
how the government are going to be able
to respond to that
um i think again she's talking about how
there could be some hope in the fact
that if you're talking about children
and mental health
they're actually much more adaptable to
online and
there could be a way of using online
resources to to do quite a bit here
but ultimately what these children have
been missing is
you know actually being in a room with
you know other children adults human
contact
and that's something that no amount of
online tuition or support can
make up for no indeed james the prime
minister has been coming under some
pressure to open the schools more
quickly or at least to give
some guidance some kind of timetable uh
as to when we can expect it
any chance the primary schools could
open after what would have been the
february midterm break but perhaps the
secondary schools
will have to wait to closer to easter
judging from what the prime minister
said yesterday andrew i think the
earliest we can expect schools to go
back it
is the 8th of march and i think that i
mean the big question is well
even primary schools james even primary
schools the big question is whether it's
a big bang reopening
with kind of all your groups going back
at the set in the same week
or whether it is as you say more
staggered with primary school children
who are
less likely to spread the virus going
back first and then secondary school
children at a later date
i think the big question here is i think
one of the challenges for the government
is
how to prevent the country from having
long covet in terms of you know
educational inequalities
and all of these issues because this is
going to take
years to wash out of the education
system uh i mean
all we know about the importance of
early as education and the like
the idea that you can take children out
of school for the amount of time they've
been out of school without this having a
lasting effect i think it's full of
birds i think it was very striking
in in casey's interview how georgia's
commissioner was talking about a much
longer term
program of catch-up work uh that than
westminster is currently thinking about
i think the government is going to have
to accept but this is going to have to
be a
permanent shift and one thing i do
wonder about is
whether those long summer holidays which
we've always known are
are are bad for educational equality
because
in crude terms uh uh middle class kids
uh do better in those holidays than
working class kids
um whether whether you know as a society
yeah
is one of the things we have to think
about getting rid of those summer
holidays you know is that going to be
one of the things we're going to have to
do
to try and level the playing field going
forward now james where are we now on
border controls it's been a long time
coming there's been a lot of talk
um are we clear now what the government
has in store
well i think this is one area where the
government is essentially admitting that
it got things wrong
earlier in the crisis it famously didn't
shut the borders you know flights came
back from wuhan and and other parts of
china
now the government is saying anyone
flying in from
a redless country essentially a country
which is which has
it either has a new variant in it or it
has close links like portugal has close
links to brazil
to a country of a new variant in it uh
we'll have to quarantine in a hotel
for 10 days um this will be much much
stricter than
than a previous quarantine policy where
you could just go to your own house and
you know the government might call you
up occasionally and ask if you were
there but
no more than that this will be you know
supervised quarantine in a hotel
uh i we now we know that the home sector
pretty patel would have liked to go
further and have done this
for people coming in from all countries
but in the end the decision was made to
limit it to
people from these at-risk uh countries i
think this is a
sign of the ways in which even if we get
back to domestic normality this summer
we're unlikely to get back to uh the
kind of classic british summer with
huge numbers of people uh jetting off on
flights to europe for a bit of sun
if you turn up the british airport and
you have a
test that says you tested negative
within
the last 72 hours what's the reason
the government is saying that you need
to quarantine i mean the theory is that
if you come
from these uh at-risk countries the risk
is so great that you were
negative 72 hours ago but you might not
be negative
right now or you might be incubating the
disease
the virus that they feel that they want
to put you into
into quarantine for that time i mean
their great fear at the moment
is that you could get a vaccine evading
variant which essentially
would require the vaccines to be tweaked
which they think can be done relatively
quickly
but then would require another mass
vaccination program which would
obviously be a body blow to the economy
and there must be some suspicion i would
have thought that if you begin
with the the the red list of the
countries the brazil's and so on that uh
particularly those that seem to have
ovarian south africa and i think another
one
that that could be extended it could go
much further than that list
yes although although the argument in
government for the current position is
that you are most likely to see the
variant where the virus is in kind of
rapid circulation
so if you can take those countries out
of the equation
you know countries with very very low
levels of kobit are unlikely to produce
a variant uh and so that is the
confidence
but i think this is the interesting
question which is you know how
we talk about uh normality i mean there
is a pretty good chance that you have
something approaching normality
domestically this summer but the more i
mean
the the more complicated question to ask
is how
when do we get back to the situation
when you can look at a holiday break
show and not think oh let me we've got
to check the red list to see whether
this country is on the list or not
um and i think this also comes back the
question that david salzberg is talking
about which is yeah
how do you ensure that you manage to
vaccinate the entire global population
that
that is a huge logistical challenge
because however much you know the the eu
and the uk are
are tussling over who gets vaccines the
rich world at the moment has
vastly more vaccine in the developing
world how do you manage to
ensure that because unless you have
managed to vaccinate essentially the
global population
there there is a risk that this virus
could come back
well it sounds like normality when it
comes to holidays james is going to be
more of a bogner than beerus
in 2020. see you in blackpool
what's wrong with bogno though i
remember what a king i
won't say the famous late king's words
i won't repeat the king's words of what
he said about boner
uh let's uh finish up this segment with
katie up
the tory back benches will they wear
this um
these international these border
controls is that something they've been
wanting or is it
does it fire up the lockdown skeptics
i think it sits fine in the short term i
think that he
speaks to lockedown skeptics actually
they think while we're in a lockdown
here
it makes sense to have tighter border
controls um i think where the crunch
will come as ultimately
these mps also think people should be
able to go on summer holidays
so let's see how this lasts in the
medium to long term
because you're also going to hear
pressure again to help out the aviation
industry
so short-term measure yes some people
think it should have been done quicker
long term i think you're going to start
to see a row james and katie thank you
for that but before i let you go james
we understand that while we've been
recording this there's been some news
out of germany that they will only
approve
astrazeneca's vaccine for the under 65s
which kind of plays to the handles black
story
we were talking about that it wasn't
effective for the over 65s
this is a remarkable development tell us
what's happening yes this touches on
what katie was saying
was saying earlier about you know what
what is you know this story
appeared in hannibal's plot a similar
story appeared and built it probably
didn't appear out of thin air
and i think we see here that the the the
robert koch institute in germany who are
in charge of the vaccination campaign
there
the financial times and the times are
both reporting that it will recommend
that uh astrazeneca is only used on
under 65s on the grounds that there is
insufficient data on its efficacy
on the over 65s to approve its use i
think it's important to stress this
isn't a safety concern
this is an efficacy concern now i
suspect that we will see the efficacy of
the oxford vaccine on the over 65s quite
quickly in the uk's numbers
either the uk's uh uh hospitalizations
and deaths among
uh the over 80s where the vast majority
have now been vaccinated will start to
drop very rapidly
uh or they won't so i think actually
this question of the efficacy of the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine on the over
65s will be settled quite quickly by
real world data from the uk but i think
this is only going to add to the
tensions
uh about uh the astrazeneca uh jab and
the eu
and i think also this uh rebuke of the
astrazeneca
i i i hardly see that is going to help
relations between the eu and the company
uh considering how horrible the eu are
playing about how astrazeneca must get
them more doses
all right well james thank you for that
it is a bizarre development we'll learn
more of it as the
uh day goes on but i guess if the
germans don't want it for the over 65s
then they won't need as much of it and
britain can continue
to supply its own over 65's with the az
vaccine
anyway what would a quarantine system
for travelers coming into the country
look like
let's hear from someone who's lived
behind close borders since march of last
year almost a year
in this week's uh spectator terry barnes
writes about the australian
experience now terry's a regular
contributor to the hugely successful
australian edition of the spectator
he's a former policy advisor to tony
abbott
former australian prime minister
quintoni abbott was
health minister terry thanks uh for
joining us from melbourne
uh just tell us how this has worked in
australia
well i mean in terms of the numbers that
we're talking about
and hearing you talk about i mean we're
dealing with roughly 30 000 covert
infections since march
we've had just over 900 covert related
deaths
including 800 in one second wave episode
in victoria
and uh and and i think at the moment
we've only got about 125
people hospitalized with uh like with um
covered so the reality is that uh
and it's very it's absolutely hard for
australians to understand
uh how britain has passed that one
hundred thousand figure because uh
with one third of the population we have
one less than one hundredth
of the covered mortality that britain
does um and that's largely because of
actions that were taken by not only the
federal government but our state and
territory
governments working with them back in
march
to one seal the borders effectively
cauterize them
because one of the advantages of being
australia of course is that we're a
great big island
with no land borders and the other thing
is that
we got going very early on the the idea
of hotel quarantine they're
effectively uh sealing off or
sequestering
travelers when they arrive in australia
so not only are
almost no people coming to the country
at the moment i think
the the allowance at the moment is 3 000
in a week
we that the hotel quarantine regime
means that uh
when it's working well uh means that
most of the cobit infections we're
seeing at the moment
and there is there is a few uh but not
very many and most of those almost all
of them now i think
as of today are in a hotel quarantine
terry these are remarkable figures i
want to come on to the quarantine issue
in a minute but just to go back
to what you're saying and to put this in
perspective for our
viewers so australia's population is
about 25 million
the united kingdom's population is under
70 million probably around about 660
so we're not yet three times uh
the people of australia
we've had over a hundred thousand deaths
australia's had fewer than a thousand
deaths
and at the moment there are only 125
active cases of covert
in the country i mean from a british
view that is a remarkable story of
success
indeed it is and uh and as look
australians
on the whole uh we may be uh
find it hard from time to time to
knuckle down to what
governments are requiring us to do to
prevent the spread of infection and
certainly here in melbourne
we were under a a very very tight
lockdown
really from july until november that was
from the local that was from the
victoria government that was from the
second wave in melbourne yes which
actually happened because the first uh
hotel quarantine program in melbourne uh
was
very badly put cobbled together very
quickly very badly run
you had untrained amateurs you know pub
bouncers security guards
actually running or doing the doing the
guarding
but also getting uh well getting
friendly with the people who they were
they were looking after so uh
you know community transmission within
the within the hotel was actually became
community transmission right across
melbourne and
it really uh showed that to make it
a success hotel quarantine programs have
to be very well managed they have to be
supervised
uh social distancing has to be
maintained which means that uh
it's no it's no it's no five-star cult
mid resort i mean it's not it's not even
a butlins holiday camp i mean basically
you're stuck in a room for a fortnight
you have no maid service
you have no room service uh your food is
brought to you and
left outside the door you basically uh
make your own bed which uh and and clean
your own room but
and you're effectively confined to
quarters with a very limited chance to
exercise
uh so it is you know as some people have
described it it is basically prison with
wi-fi
and just to clarify the first wave of
attempting this
um actually resulted in a spreading of
the pandemic because it wasn't being
done
professionally enough the the security
wasn't professional i think you
mentioned in your articles that again
sort of nightclub bouncers were brought
in to kind of keep
people there now the military's been
involved the police are involved the
medical system is involved
and that has made it much more of a
success is that right
i think that's right i mean lessons were
learned from what happened in melbourne
and what happened
with certainly early troubles in other
states as well
and and now i think programs around the
country and each each
state capital city has their own hotel
quarantine regime
effectively have contained the virus in
terms of community transmission in
in the big states new south wales
victoria and queensland there's but well
i think
in victoria my state uh we haven't had a
new community case in about three weeks
uh new south wales basically has got a
clean bill of health
in the last couple of days and uh
internal borders in australia and that's
been a
another issue with hotel quarantine and
quarantine generally is that
states have been closing their borders
to other states which
has effectively pitted australia against
australia and i think that's been the
worst aspect of
the whole covered experience for us
but as far as the international side
goes i think people have accepted it
uh even even people you know who are on
the um
certainly on the more liberal or
certainly
very much the uh personal freedom side
of
side of the side of the agenda uh
they've really
accepted that one you've got to do these
things for the common good and two
if you are traveling you are returning
home or you're coming from overseas as a
foreigner at least
this is the price you pay for
re-entering or entering australia
do you think it could work in britain uh
you're you say in your article in the
spectator this week you know it's a
australia it's an island continent it's
a long way away from
uh other places you really have to fly
there most people have to
do that the populations are different
it's not a global
hub in the way that britain london in
particular is a global hub
uh plus you've done it from the start
we're only talking about it now
almost a year in that is it something
other lessons for britain
well i think uh it's reported that uh
pretty patel
wanted to shut the borders really from
the start back in march and i think
if you've done that so you wouldn't have
as well a fraction of the problem that
you have at the moment over there
but the other side of it is that you
have to get a balance right between
keeping the country open keeping the
economy going keeping
keeping people in jobs and because you
are
at the thing that really actually the
thing that really
gobsmacks me about what the government
has announced in britain
with this uh 22 country hot list
is i can't see how it's going to work
successfully because the thing about
what we have done
is that we went all the way uh we shut
down borders
as totally as we could we basically
ensured that
people wherever they came from went into
quarantine to to be selective
uh for all 22 countries who are on the
list
okay but you know there are 200 odd
countries around the world and most of
them have people who
want to go to britain or want to pass
through britain and
i and and viruses don't actually
recognize foreign borders they don't
recognize frontiers they
they go where they where they go and uh
there's no
i think certain guarantee that what is
being what has been announced is going
to actually be
a magic bullet in the way that it's been
talked about i can see that final
question terry just on the australian
experience there are very few flights as
i understand it now to australia and
uh what flights there are very expensive
uh
that you if you arrive there and go to
quarantine you have to pay for that it's
about
seventeen hundred pounds uh for an
individual and
a bit less if there are then more people
involved there's a lot of money the
consequence of that has been that there
are forty
000 australian citizens who are stranded
abroad if i can put it that way
is the government under no pressure to
do something to bring them home
the government's under quite a lot of
pressure on that andrew
but as i said before the the current
limit on
new arrivals to australia in a week is
three thousand
uh that's uh uh what half a dozen jumbo
jets
uh that's uh not enough to to get to
well uh any a fraction of the
uh australians who are stranded abroad
home uh but
uh yes i think the government is under
pressure they've certainly
uh increased the number of flights that
they have chartered that they are paying
for to bring people home
but it's still going to take some time
and again i think there's been some
broad
uh resignation part of those who are
stranded from what i'm hearing but also
i think
in terms of the australian community
they see it as
a price we've had to pay in order to
keep australia as covert free as we
possibly can make it
all right terry we'll leave it there
terry barnes of spectator australia
thank you very much for joining us on
spectator tv
uh from melbourne uh now remember if you
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel for free you'll
never miss another episode just click
the subscribe button at the bottom right
of the screen now finally this year the
office of prime minister of british
prime minister
marks its 300th anniversary
yeah 1721 walpole
should there be a museum dedicated to
downing street
and its occupants to mark the occasion
historian and biographer of numerous
prime ministers anthony selden
he argues in this week's edition of the
spectators that there should be
and he joins us now anthony welcome to
spectator
tv why do you think you know
you bring up the point that every
president now uh
in the america has their own library and
a bespoke building and scholars can go
and study all the papers and so on
why have we never done anything like
that for british prime ministers
well andrew the prime minister of course
is not head of state
um unlike the 45 u.s
presidents so there's an extra dimension
there but effectively
the prime minister has taken over many
of the responsibilities of the head of
state
so when robert warpole back in april
1721 was invited to be first board of
the treasury
and chancellor of the exchequer the
office was combined at the time
um he was in awe
of george the first george ii from 1727
and they were powerful people so i think
it's something about
um the fact that you know america
there's more money but there's also
head of state and i think we need to
have more reverence
and um recognition of the importance of
this office on this anniversary
if it's not done now andrew when will it
be done i thought
your article in this week's spectator i
thought was fascinating is you reminded
us
of the incredibly important decisions
not just for britain but for the whole
world that were taken
in that cabinet room in 10 downing
street with prime ministers cheering
them
decisions that in the end lost as the 13
colonies and led to the
declaration of independence decisions to
go to war
against germany in 1914
1939 huge global
decisions and yet we we
have no museum that that deals with this
it's it is a remarkable uh gap is it not
it is i mean it is uh the
most famous address in the world
um the us was governed
from downing street for its first 55
years
until the declaration of independence
and so it's very important to the
americans but it's important to
india it's important to china it's um
that this from this office and
not least in the 19th century when
britain
was arguably the most important power
in the globe um the decisions were
pumped out of that
uh office and and so
it's not just a british asset it's a
global treasure
uh and what's so funny is that you know
it's still being used as
an office and people who work in there
uh
are really pretty unaware of
of the history of it which is exactly
why
i thought this would be a good idea i've
been down the street quite a few times
but
it was your article that brought home to
me uh
the history over that i hadn't really
thought enough about
if we had a museum of prime ministers or
whatever we call it anthony
what would be in it how do you envisage
this museum
well i think we have to ask who would it
be
for uh and we have to accept the fact
that
unlike the white house where and many
other
uh offices of heads of state and heads
of government
across the world where visitors can come
in
so there is a a public education role in
that
you can't do it in downing street
because it's
too small too awkward i mean it's wildly
improbable
this terraced house uh in a pretty
unpre-possessing
street um has become uh this great
office it wasn't purpose-built
uh like um the elysee like um
the viceroy's palace and there's a white
house
yeah and the white house and the white
house in your article that if
for some prime ministers before just
really it wasn't grand enough so they
didn't
it was it was i mean can you imagine
wellington
uh you know if he's got his house on
hyde park
one hyde park yeah absolutely i mean you
know i mean
why would you want to go and live in
this
very smelly dirty sinking
grubby house so some of them did i mean
pit did uh
and um appealed it and walpole
uh did but a lot of the grandes who
tended to be
prime minister so i think what you'd do
is you would have a
replica of the most important rooms in
that building and not just
i think it's also important that it's
regionally spread also
uh so that you know there is one up in
edinburgh there is one uh
in cardiff and in belfast too so there's
a sense
of it being the office of um
of the whole of the united kingdom
rather than the prime minister for the
southeast of england which is
often uh not least by didn't of the
derivation of the prime minister's what
it seemed to be
so let's finish on this and uh you know
let's hope your idea takes off
spectators who can help on that we'd be
delighted uh to to do so
uh helping raise some money and and so
on but
so 300 years of british prime ministers
going back to walpole
uh in 1721.
let me ask you about the best or the
worst in two
sections let's take since 1945
modern times if we can call it that over
the past
70 odd years
who have been the best prime ministers
two contenders
andrew both wildly different the second
one largely undid the work of the first
and they're clement actly from 1945 to
51 the labour prime minister
who achieved what lloyd george didn't
after the first world war
in 1918 of building a land fit for
heroes introducing
the social and economic policies that
set the tone for the next 30 years
and positioned britain's place in the
world in the un
found a member of nato atomic um
power atomic power in the world and
independence for india and much more so
really
a defining administration the second one
obviously margaret thatcher
from 1979 to 1990 not just
um because she was the first woman um
she won
three general elections first time since
liverpool
at the beginning of the 19th century but
she remolded the whole
uh shape of of britain um and unpicking
much of what
atlee had done so i mean
on the world stage a giant figure the
most
uh significant prime minister globally
since 1945
by a distance so they're the two giants
i agree with that i think that atlee and
thatcher are the two
most significant uh prime ministers
since 1945 because we're exactly for the
reasons you
gave okay let me go to before 39. now
you've
noticed i've missed out sir 40 to 45.
uh with your agreement i hope i'm i'm
parking churchill
as being suey generous uh
in roy jenkins biography biography of
him he does he despite
being the huge admirer of gladstone he
says he was the greatest
prime minister let me park church
churchill
before 1939 who would you mark out
as our greatest prime ministers well i
think warpol
because he created the office still the
longest-serving
prime minister andrew 21 years and he so
nearly got flipped out at different
points it was
pretty tenuous often his survival not
least when
george the first his great patron died
uh then you go to pitt the younger who
really consolidated the office
without pip being there for most of the
time between
1783 and 1806 during the
revolutionary napoleonic wars holding
the country together
and he took on foreign policy as i
understand it which previously
had really been the palace around
foreign policy absolutely i mean
resting it out of the control of um
george iii he was a much more activist
um
uh king than his george one and two and
but you know he'd got his fingers so
badly burnt on foreign policy
with the american civil war and the loss
of the 13
colonies that he lost his confidence
and pitt uh was supremely confident
in directing that war but consolidating
the post and then i think very briefly
you have to go to gladstone uh because
he
uh shaped the premiership for the era of
mass political parties
and the the beginning of the mass
franchise beginning programmatic
politics
the idea that you put a program to
the public in a general election i think
you have to finish off
then with lloyd george um absolute
scandal
arguably the biggest scandal there are
lots of contenders since warpole
perhaps ever but he did see the country
successfully through the last
two years of the first world war and
dynamic at the treaty of versailles
uh getting britain's position banging
there
in the post-war settlement and solving
the irish question
uh you know the question andrew is why
there's so few
great prime ministers compared to say
german chancellors since 1945
or indeed u.s presidents many of them
have disappointed
indeed there's good choices there i
think anthony you've got a book coming
out on british prime ministers haven't
you
in um beginning of april with cambridge
where i tried to bring together i wrote
it during covic but really
for 40 years i've been writing about
prime ministers so it was nice to be
able to
pull all that together and think you
know why has the office survived is it
still the same office
who accept your question you know who
are the great ones
and why and why are there not more but
also how can we
improve the office for the fourth decade
for the fourth century
and the title of your book uh impossible
office with a question mark
impossible has it just become impossible
to succeed anthony selden thank you for
your time today on spectator tv it's
great to talk to you
thank you that's it for this week thanks
to all of our guests uh
and once again of course to our very
special sponsor charles stanley
they continue to sponsor the week in 60
minutes charles stanley is one
of the uk's leading wealth management
firms one of the oldest firms on the
london stock exchange
we are delighted to have them as our
partners a final reminder
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel it's free
you never miss another episode just
click the subscribe button
at the bottom right of the screen now as
always send us
your thoughts on spectator tv 2
spectator tv at spectator dot co dot uk
and join us again next week until then
bye bye
[Music]
you